it's been a while since we had a
successful or I guess even attempted
murder of someone associated with Russia
under sketchy circumstances and by a
while I mean it's been a few months I
guess and the BBC is now reporting that
a nerve agent was used to try to kill a
former Russian spy and his daughter
sergey skripnikov
was sentenced to 13 years in Russian
prison for passing intelligence to some
British intelligence agents mi6 agents
from the UK in the UK and he was
eventually released by Moscow a few
years ago in 2010 in exchange for 10
Russian spies that had previously been
arrested by the FBI and Sergei scribble
and his daughter Yulia scrip all were
found unconscious in the UK over the
weekend and they still remain in
critical condition as of just a few
hours ago
the police officer who was the first
responder to the scene is also in
critical condition because the poison
used is very very deadly it's a nerve
agent which is so toxic that it can stop
the nervous system from working properly
or at all when it succeeds in killing
people it shuts down basic bodily
functions it often enters through the
nose or mouth but it can also go in
through the eyes or even be absorbed
through the skin and this is being
considered sort of a parallel incident
to when former Russian spy Alexander
Litvinenko was poisoned in London about
12 years ago which was later determined
to have been approved by Vladimir Putin
personally and even the use of a nerve
agent like this tells us a lot because
if you're part of a gang if you're a
street criminal even mafias right they
don't typically have the means to make
nerve agents or even to get them usually
these nerve agents come from labs that
are often directly tied into governments
so immediately looking at the background
of Sergei script all and looking at the
mechanism that was used the focus
becomes Russia here and Russia also has
a track record of using these types of
poisons they have a sort of more general
track record of assassinating political
enemies and
students and Sergei scribble you look at
his background there's some pretty
specific motive there right he was
providing information to British
intelligence and he was formerly
imprisoned previously imprisoned by
Russia and they're sort of very clear
motive here and every time this happens
there's this question of why now
right like why now given that this guy
has been out of prison for eight years
living in the UK why would Russia go
after him now that's also actually a
calling card of the Russians a long time
can go by you might think that maybe
they'd forgotten or you know that they
don't forget and thus you're living
these entire eight years in fear and
then the poison shows up and this is
actually one of the more sinister cases
because usually Russia will only go
after the person themselves this time
his daughter also is in critical
condition and we don't know whether she
was sort of collateral damage because
these nerve agents are so deadly or
whether she was actually targeted by the
poisoner but even if she was collateral
damage the fact that this was done with
no regard for possible collateral damage
is pretty gross and something else for
the Russia deniers here which there will
no doubt be many of in the current
climate Matt Tate pointed out on Twitter
that when you use a poison like this
you're kind of deliberately using it so
that it will be known who did it right
he tweeted anyone can fall off a balcony
or get shot in the street but using
isotopes that only occur in specific
reactors or VX that only a few
nation-states have labs that can make
isn't an accident
it's messaging you betray us we kill you
and your Western handlers won't save you
now the only problem with that of course
is that you can make it so that anybody
who wants to frame someone who regularly
uses this stuff would be able to pretty
easily do it by using the poison that
you're known to use but again these are
not exactly poisons that you can get
over-the-counter or whatever the
equivalent would be to an
over-the-counter poison these are only
obtainable from a very limited number of
specific places
that are able to produce this stuff you
use these poisons to send a message
right if they wanted this whoever it was
to look like a suicide they could have
sometimes that's still suspicious like
we've reported on suspicious suicides
that don't really seem to be suicides
but they could have done it if they
wanted it to look like a simple murder
maybe a robbery gone wrong they could
have made an attempt to do that
they didn't right they actually chose to
use the nerve the nerve gas and by the
way meanwhile are you as excited as I am
for World Cup soccer action in Russia
starting in just a few months I've heard
about that I actually I mean I it's
disgusting it's disgusting that the
World Cup is actually going to be in
Russia a country that not only has
meddled in our elections and has tried
to circumvent and and as sort of a
impact destabilize democracy in the
United States so many times but even
just the corruption to get the World Cup
I mean it is all so disgusting and if it
weren't for the fact that I love World
Cup soccer I would be boycotting the
yeah hire thing and I really hope that
you don't attend because it's really
hard to host the David Pakman show
poisoned yeah and you have 50 stab
wounds in your back so listen I was
recently talking to former producer
Louis how much time do I have not not
that much I'll tell this very quickly I
was talking to a former producer Louis
and he has a plan in late summer to go
to st. Petersburg because you can enter
if you enter from like one of the
Scandinavian countries you can get in
for three days without needing a visa
that you would normally need I think to
go from the US and he said you should
you should come and meet up and I know
that North Korea I would not want to go
to even though I would find it
fascinating just because of the coverage
from the program I'd be worried that I'd
be on some list right I kind of think
I'd be worried about the same thing in
Russia at this point I really do and I
don't know if that's that's irrational
but I would hesitate to fly to Russia at
this point or to go in if something
happened to you it would be a major
story but that's true that's not really
what you're thinking about it no you
know what I know any publicity is good
publicity but ending up in some kind of
Russian prison is not really the
publicity that I'm looking for it could
be great for the show but we'd have to
find someone else to host the show that
would benefit from me ending up in a
Russian prison and speaking of which not
to go Russia overload on you
next is the conclusion
to our piece on what we know so far
about the Trump Russia story today's
program is made possible in part by
fruit or which is a social forecasting
game for your phone where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you go on the app
find a future event you feel confident
enough about to make a prediction and
make a bet on the outcome that you think
will happen using the apps in-game fake
currency if your prediction is right
you're rewarded with more points you can
compete with others who are making their
own prediction to see who is the best
forecaster there's no real world money
or cryptocurrency involved the fun of
but--or is interacting with others and
showing the world your skills at
predicting the future will Democrats
take the White House house this year
will Trump run for re-election will
Trump ever build the wall you can go
ahead and make your predictions show off
your forecasting skills and there are
also monthly competitions and prizes for
top forecasters and I'm on food tour you
can wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions to go to fruit or
calm to sign up and make forecast it's
free it's on Android and iOS as well as
on web browsers and it's spelled fut you
you are calm